you know I have my issues with season 1
but man he makes it look good Luke Cage
season 2 trailer is out and let's talk
about it um I don't have the same level
of expectations going into this one that
he did with say Jessica Jones season 2
which because I loved the first season
of Jessica Jones so much I was really
worried that there was nowhere to go but
down and I kind of feel like that's what
happened Luke Cage the first season to
reiterate quickly I loved him I loved
him I loved misty I loved cottonmouth
I liked Mariah I liked shades I didn't
like Diamondback I didn't like the
accesing excessive delving into Luke's
backstory I feel I felt like the entire
second half of the season was just
weaker pretty much across the board so I
am hoping that this one will be stronger
will stand up better will be more
consistent than the first season was I
have no doubt that Mike Colter is going
to nail the part he has nailed Luke Cage
every single time he showed up on screen
we get misty back I like her a lot
Claire's back I love Claire who else
would go we've got we've got Luke's
friend from the barbershop he's still
around happy to see that we get our
first look at our new villain I
character called bushmaster who is a
character I do not know so I've got no
preconceptions about what to expect from
him I I'm kind of two minds in terms of
basically just having a guy strong
enough to beat up Luke Cage cut its
weird part of me feels like they did
that last time but they didn't really it
was only kind of at the very end when
diamondback had his very dumb looking
suit that he that he took Luke Cage on
hand to hand although he did you know
have the gun
like that could pierce his skin but I
don't know it I feel like I would like a
different angle than just oh now there's
somebody who can actually beat him up
but it's not a bad way to go and if the
villain is charismatic enough and
well-developed enough that could work
I mean maybe part of the reason I have
reservations about that was I really
wanted to see Mariah come into her own
as a villain because her turn on
cottonmouth was probably my single
favorite moment of the first season one
of my favorite moments and Marvel
Netflix at all and it was the peak of
that season it was all downhill after
that
but I do like her a lot and I like
shades and I like their dynamic is kind
of a gender swapped Lady Macbeth and
Macbeth you know pairing and I I do I
like that so I'm looking forward to that
but of course we only get glimpses of
them this is petty but I'll just say it
the fire effects so bad like look guys
if you're not gonna shell out the money
to be able to afford fire effects that
look good just don't do them okay cuz
they know your limits it looked bad but
I I am there's a lot that I'm excited
here for and I like the vibe I liked the
vibe of the first one and it feels it
feels authentic it feels homegrown and
it feels true to the character
it feels earned it doesn't feel like a
veneer of trying to push the hip-hop
hero it feels like a natural extension
of him as a character so it it works
when it could feel like pandering so
yeah bye hello oh god and reg Kathy the
late reg Kathy who you know was in the
wire and fantastic unfortunate don't
hold that against him but he's a great
presence and he's and this he
unfortunately he passed away earlier
this year so this is the last thing he
made but I'm excited to see what they
what they do with him because he's
always a great
presents and a performance so I like
this cast pretty much all the returning
characters I like I'm just hoping that I
got the big question mark for me right
now is the villain is bushmaster because
what I'm seeing I'm like this could work
but I'm also not sold it especially
knowing in the back of my head I'm way
more interested in Mariah than I am with
this guy so that's that's my main point
of concern right now is how well
Bushmaster works as a villain because if
he doesn't that could end up being the
big weak spot cuz pretty much everything
else I see in this aside from the fire
effects is a reason for me to be excited
for the show to be back so I'm I am
hopeful
I'm not pumped because I was let down
enough by the first season that I'm not
gonna let myself get pumped but I'm I'm
I'm hopeful and I want to see where this
goes and yeah jimm looking forward to it
so Luke Cage season 2 trailer did you
see it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do so just support me on patreon follow
me on Twitter look into my podcast and
all this other stuff links for all that
stuff is down in the description so
until next time this council is juror
don't know why I said it like that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]